فتتابع اذا ما ما يحدث هذه التطورات وهذا
الانسحاب سفيان كان واضحا اليوم بان
التحرك في المنطقه الوسطى لقطاع غزه تشي
بشيء ما ونحن لاحظنا حقيقه تحركا كثيفا
للدبابات الاسرائيليه في منطقه البريج
والمناطق الشرقيه في داخل غلاف غزه عند
المخيمات الوسطى وكذلك الجبات العسكريه
والاليات العسكريه التي تم سحبها على على
الاقل في الساعه الاخيره وقت وقوع العمليه
في مدينه رعنانا وكان واضحا منذ ساعات
الصباح ان ما يجري في البريج هو شيء غريب
ونحن قلنا ذلك في تغطيتنا الصحفيه صباح
هذا اليوم من عين المكان وقلنا بان القتال
كان شرسا وعنيفا مقارنه مع الاسابيع
الماضيه وان كانت مخيم البريج والنصيرات
والمغازي وغيرها قد شهدت قتالا عنيفا لكن
الواضح ان القتال الذي استمر حتى الساعه
الاخيره من انسحاب هذه الفرقه يعني الفرقه
انسحبت تحت وابل من النيران تحت وابل من
المقاومه ويبدو ان الغارات الجويه العنيفه
التي كنا نشاهدها معكم صباح هذا اليوم من
منطقه غلاف غزه والغطاء الدخاني الذي كان
موجود بكثافه وكذلك قنابل الاناره التي
اضيئت في اكثر من موقع في منطقه البريج
كانت كما يبدو للتغطيه والتعم وا محاوله
الانس لهذه القوات المؤله الى داخل منطقه
غلاف غزه كان واضحا ونحن في طريقنا الى
تلي ابيب ان قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي بدات
ايضا بازاله بعض مواقع المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه على المناطق في غلاف غزه
مناطق التخوم
وكنا نشير ونرى بان الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
يقلل من اعداد البطاريات المدفعيه
الموجوده في منطقه غلاف غزه على الاقل في
اليومين الماضيين وكان هذا لافتا هذا
اليوم وتحديدا في ساعات العصر حيث كانت
الشرطه العسكريه الاسرائيليه قد اغلقت
عددا من محاور الطرق في منطقه غلاف غزه
لتامين دخول ووصول الشاحنات الى موقع تجمع
الدبابات والمدفعيه من اجل نقلها الى
اماكن اخرى فرقه رقم 36 هي الفرقه التي
بدات العمليه العسكريه في المناطق
الشماليه في اقصى المناطق الشماليه لقطاع
غزه منذ اليوم الاول للعمليات العسكريه
البريه عملت في بيت حنون وفي بيت لاهيه
وفي مخيم الشاطئ وفي جباليا ودخلت الى
الشجاعيه وبعد ذلك التفت الى الضواحي
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه ووصلت الى منطقه جحر
الديك وتقدمت بعد ذلك الى مخيمات البريج
وصراط والمغازي الى ان انسحبت هذا اليوم
بحسب بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن ان هذه الفرقه قد
اخرجت من العمليات العسكريه من اجل انعاشه
ومن اجل اي او في اطار العمليات العسكريه
ويقول بان ال سحب هذه الفرقه لا يعني
عمليا انتهاء المعارك ولكن هو يسحب هذه ال
الفرقه كتكتيك بحسب بيانه او كجزء من
المعركه من اجل انعاش القوات ومن اجل
اجراء ترتيبات واعاده ترتيب صفوف هذه
الفرقه وربما الزج بها اذا احتاج الجيش
الاسرائيلي ذلك مره اخرى في ارض المعركه
لكن كان واضحا سفيان هذا اليوم بان الفرقه
رقم 36 عندما انسحبت من منطقه البريج
والمناطق الشرقيه للمخيم هي انسحبت تحت
قتال عنيف وقتال دار مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهذا يعني بان هذه الفرقه لم
تنجز المهمه العسكريه وهذا ربما المقاومه
الفلسطينيه سوف توضحه في قادم الايام او
ربما في قادم الساعات لان انسحاب هذه
الفرقه جاء كما اشرت تحت عمليات مقاومه
شرسه وقويه كنا شهودا عليها هذا الصباح في
منطقه غلاف غزه عند البريج وكانت تجري
عمليه الانسحاب تحت وابل كثيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه من ناحيه وتحت غطاء جوي كثيف
من الغارات الجويه وقنابل الدخان وق
وقنابل الاضاءه التي كان هدفها التعميه او
الارشاد في مرات اخرى للقو قت للانسحاب
كان واضحا بان الدبابات الاسرائيليه في
منطقه البريج كانت تنسحب وتخرج الى داخل
مناطق الغلاف وتتموضع عند مناطق بعينها
وكذلك كثير من الجبات العسكريه وما
يرافقها من عتاد واليات عسكريه كانت تنسحب
من تلك ال المناطق عندما غادرناها اذا
الاهم في هذه النقطه هو ان الفرقه 36 التي
بدات هذه العمليه البريه في ال 26 من
اكتوبر تنسحب وتنسحب كما يبدو دون انجاز
المهمه العسكريه الموكله اليها لاننا كما
قلنا انسحبت تحت وابل كثيف من النيران
والغطاء الجوي ويبدو ان هذا ربما يكون
مؤشر سفيان على ان اسرائيل بدات تفكر في
المرحله الثالثه في مرحله ما بعد العمليات
العسكريه الكبرى بمعنى اعاده انتشار
للقوات اعاده تموضع للقوات ليس بالضروره
انس احب كامل للقوات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
من المناطق الشماليه انما اعاده تموضع
واعاده انتشار في داخل مناطق ربما دمرتها
قريبه من السياج الامني او في داخل منطقه
غلاف غزه هذا من ناحيه ومن ناحيه
اخرى الياس قبل ان تكمل كلامك يعني لدينا
صور هنا متوفره نستطيع ان نشاهدها على
الشاشه اذا لانسحاب الفرقه 36 اذا قبل
قليل من القطاع كما تحدثت اذا ل او بغيه
اذا انعاش القوات الاسرائيليه اي اعود
اليك الياس اذا وتحليلك وفي الواقع كلامك
يتقاطع مع الكثير مما قاله اللواء
الدويري نعم بالفعل وكنت اشير الى نقطه في
غايه الاهميه وهو سؤال مشروع اين تتوجه
هذه الاليات العسكريه الان لا نعرف لا
نستطيع ان نجزم حقيقه ولكن هل سحب هذه
الفرقه الان مع مجموعات من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه يعني بان اسرائيل تريد ان
تقلل من وجودها العسكري ومن الياتها
العسكريه في منطقه في المنطقه الشماليه
لقطاع غزه من اجل من اجل الزج بهذه القوات
الى جنوب قطاع غزه ام ربما تكون الانظار
الان الى الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه
التي سخنت في الايام الماضيه وربما تكون
اسرائيل معنيه في سحب بعض قواتها وفرقها
والويتر الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه وربما
مفاجاه الجميع بحرب استباقيه او بضربه
استباقيه للمقاومه اللبنانيه هناك نحن
نعلم ان الجبهه اللبنانيه تسخن بشده في
الايام الماضيه والجيش الاسرائيلي يقول
بانه جاهز لحرب وجاهز لمعركه صحيح بان
الاداره الامريكيه يبدو انها تحاول اقناع
اسرائيل بعدم زج نفسها بمعركته جبهتين
بمعنى معركتين كبيرتين حربين كبيرين لان
المرح الحرب لم تنتهي بعد في قطاع غزه وان
تفتح على نفسها ايه بابا جديدا او حربا
جديده على الحدود مع لبنان هذا الامر وارد
جدا وا لكن دعني اشير ايضا الى ان بنيامين
نتنياهو بدا يصغي ايضا كما يبدو الى
القيادات العسكريه التي تحذره من احتمال
ان يغوص الجيش الاسرائيلي في وحل قطاع غزه
لانه من الواضح سفيان بان العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في الايام الاخيره
تحديدا منذ بدايه العام الجديد بدات
مترهله وبدات وكانها تراوح في مكانها دون
اي شيء جديد تنجزه على الارض والقوات
الاسرائيليه لم تعد قادره على تحقيق اي
انجاز عسكري على ارض المعركه لا في شمالها
ولا في وسطها ولا في جنوبها اي لا على
صعيد اي القضاء على حركه حماس عسكريا
وسلطوية
فعز هذا الصباح استمعنا الى ما قاله
الجنرال المتقاعد يتسحاك بريك ونحن ناتي
على ذكره كثيرا لانه هو الجنرال الوحيد
الذي كان قد توقع ايه هجمات او هجوم ال
السابع من اكتوبر بحذافيره وكانه هو الذي
كتبه بالتفصيل وبالسين وحذر منه منذ شهور
كثيره ولم يلتفت له احد لذلك حديثه وما
يصرح به في الايام الاخيره اصبح في
الاعلام الاسرائيلي وكانه ايه مقدس ان صح
التعبير وبين هلالين لذلك هو يقول هذا
الصباح ان على الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يعيد
التفكير ماليا في العمليه العسكريه في
داخل قطاع غزه ليس فقط في المناطق
الشماليه وال والوسطى انما عليه ان يعيد
التفكير في طريقه عمليته العسكريه حتى في
منطقه خانيونس وهو قالها بصراحه على الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يسحب قواته العسكريه فورا
من خانيونس لان المعركه هناك تكبد الجيش
الاسرائيلي قتل وجرحى وتكبره خسائر فادحه
وكبيره ولا تحقق لا الهدف العسكري المرجو
لها ولا الهدف
باستعاده الاسرى المحتجزين في داخل قطاع
غزه وهذا الموقف يتقاطع ايضا مع ما قاله
ايضا بالامس جادي ايزنكوت عضو مجلس الحرب
وهو يجلس في مجلس الحرب في صفه مراقب
عندما قال علينا ان نهم ان لا نوهم انفسنا
بما يمكن ان نحقق هو على الصعيد العسكري
وكان يوجه كلامه لاعضاء مجلس الحرب في هذا
السياق وكان يدفع مجلس الحرب الى وقف
العمليات العسكريه كما يبدو
وا الجنوح الى تفاوض من اجل اطلاق سراح
الاسرى الاسرائيليين في شكرا جزيلا لك
الياس كرام كنت معنا من تلبيب